okay let's go to our caller from the 267
area code who's calling from 2 6 7 today
it should be Jimmy from Chloe hey Jimmy
what's going on
well you know you know David I hear you
talking about are you in a good face of
meaningful conversations and yet the way
I heard you just described Trump
supporters was in bad things you can
three subsections one or ignorant to two
[ __ ] or three to bad people how is
that a good faith argument to tell me
that David how is that having a
meaningful conversation well explain to
me someone who's outside of those three
categories okay why did you vote for
Trump what do you mean what why not go
for Tom my god the reasons are because
because I can't stand politicians
because they've been lying for years hey
hey let's take them one by one let's
take them one by one if you voted for
Trump because you don't like politicians
I would consider that an ignorant reason
to vote for Trump your second reason was
because other politicians lie Trump lies
all the time that's also not a good
Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy hold on a second let's
take it one step at a time the two
reasons you cited for voting for Trump I
would characterize as extraordinarily
ignorant so you're not providing where
she would because you don't like Trump
of course you would know hold on a
second Jimmy if you called and you said
I voted for any candidate because
politicians lie I would consider that an
ignorant reason it has nothing to do and
now you describe that how is that
ignorant because it's true
politicians do lines let's face it we
know it you don't know there's that the
why does the fact that politician
because I think the vision because I
think erupting me I'm gonna hang up on
you you still there Jimmy yeah I'm here
okay my question is how is reaching the
decision to vote for any
particular candidate because in history
politicians have lied not ignorant
you're adding more to it I don't know I
just give you a sampling answer David
Jimmy Jimmy why are you so angry because
you just been followed every Trump
supporter and I don't like that day but
you're disingenuous no actually I was
completely genuine in my analysis number
two to [ __ ] it another three to bad
people
Jimmy record David Ellis had a good
faith argument Jimmy can we take it one
day at a time or is that not possible
David you know what you're annoying I'm
hanging up on you okay thank you man
Jimmy just shot out of a cannon